[Music]
as a teen
very very slow development didn't really
grow much at round 14 15 i had to kind
of two
sus the non injections growth enhancer
that time your life is quiet you see all
the guys you know
going out getting a sports team getting
girls and that's what you want to do you
want to be you want to join in and be
part
eddie hey how are you doing pleasure to
meet you buddy this is alex
welcome to the beast mansion yeah well i
want to see that the beast
when you were a kid you were very very
much smaller than the other guys yeah
being at 14 i was around 32 kilos
wow jeez my i mean i've got a
seven-year-old boy that's near 40 kilos
what do you want to change
yeah just a bit bigger one over like 55
16. i think we've got a lot to work with
here
i think we should have some fun right
i'm gonna i'm gonna bring the team in
luke and chris
[Music]
these two are my right and left hand men
[Music]
10.87 geez 10 body fat you don't
you don't see that in elite athletes do
you
also love seeing that titanic so that
won't fit around your waist
what inch waist are you 26 7.
there you go i've got a 32-inch quad
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well done dude
we've had so far
[Music]
you've done your whole body weight for
91 meters
come on come on come on
get it get it keep going
you fumbled and you still got 21.9
that's fast social record again 13.1
seconds
there's one more thing before we send
you on your way we want to take some
before and after pictures
okay they turn to your right 90 degree
mate you've
honestly done i'm super impressed thank
you pleasure i think you're gonna do
really well on this six weeks
it's exactly like the captain america
analogy he's because he's too short he's
too slight
he can't join the army but he's got a
heart of the lion and that's exactly
what he showed today
if he gives us what he's given us today
good job i'm hungry
in front of me i've got a daily kind of
intake of my food
currently got my egg whites cooking i've
got these oats which i'll have with some
almond milk
looking for the rest today
i just had a big uh shoulders and back
session yesterday feeling sore i do have
diving later so
i'm not sure how it's gonna affect that
or whether i'm gonna even go
so it's week two i'm finding chicken a
little bit boring they're like
pre-soaked chicken chicken
hopefully that's allowed there's not too
many many fats or salts in that
hey alex hope you're well buddy i've
been following your progress and it
looks like you've been smashing it i'm
sending chris and luke to check up on
you
and give you some support how have you
found the increase in calories because
it's a massive increase
the first i say three or four days
trying to expand my stomach
yeah was hard um but now after a week
it's easier in terms of the volume
yeah but now i'm starting to find it's
the just the plain chicken is getting
boring
how are you finding sleep and recovery
not done this before but waking up to
need a piss
i guess sometimes twice night at like
three and six when you get up for a piss
mate have a protein shake
what do you think about what alex is
putting himself through at the moment
and the changes that are going on i
think it's great so i'm actually younger
than alex but people always used to
think i was the older sister
um because alex used to be a whole head
shorter than me i think people notice it
as well and especially when you're a
teenager people don't hold back and if
you're short then they'll call you out
for it which they certainly did
yeah so we had a big family party last
weekend
did he get drunk just seen alex he's
been doing exactly what he's told us
he's been doing
i'm really excited to see what the final
package that he's going to bring at the
end
i've got good hopes for alex
so it's week four currently looking for
a job
having a bit of a bad day not really
feeling it for the gym but
got a soldier on
hey alex how are you bro howdy how you
doing i'm good
you can see you've packed over your
weight on just from your face really
yeah you really can yeah how are you
getting on with the deadlift i know that
was one of your weaker points when we
were doing the tests
i was actually mentioned to luke my
mental arithmetic went in the gym and i
was made
according to my program do 85 kilos for
five
reps but and i actually had 19 above so
i just
i didn't realize and i still bought five
i just want to say you're doing an
awesome job i can see you doing really
well
another four kilos is doable so stick to
the diet stick the training
and uh i'm fairly confident i'm gonna
see the captain america we all want to
see in a few weeks
so i've just spoke to alex on skype but
literally his face is filled out his
shoulders are filled out
uh i just feel as though his confidence
is lacking a little bit
you know i've done my best to try and
encourage alex yeah it's a tough one
like what would it do for you in your
life not just because you'd be in a
good physical shape but how would it
make you feel in your life if you felt
better about
yourself in that sense you just can't
say how much it would mean just like you
know just
i wish i could ask alex of 10 years ago
because i've been
able to answer that with a lot
take a seat you know what he's been so
disciplined i've said to him a couple of
times over the last couple of weeks do
you want
you want to go for a drink do you want a
trip to the pub every time he's been
like no corinne oh i think i can go at
the end but i really want to concentrate
on it
hopefully he's put the size on what i
think it's going to do for his
confidence and his general well-being
he's always been obsessed with like
trying to put on weight like always like
looked up to like bodybuilders and stuff
but he's just never been able to
like follow through with it he's always
had the most like lively of
personalities he's always been the joker
he's always been hilarious
but he's just always been so aware of it
it's just that sort of this aspect of
his life that made him ever so slightly
different to everyone else
feeling super nervous
[Music]
you definitely pack some weight on here
buddy yeah
so you're up 2.6 kilos your lean masses
up
2.7 kilos so your body fat's actually
dropped from 10
10.8 10.9 to like 10.10
max deadlift 100 kilos was your max last
time get your straps on and
let's get you warmed up
jesus christ did you think 10 kilo aside
120. i'm gonna say 120
i'd say 120. show us what you can do
buddy because i'm telling you now
there's not many people that can
deadlift 120 kilos
134 is two and a half body weight right
so if you can do two and a half body
weight
that honestly puts you kind of like the
elite in the strength world
honestly pound per pound i can only pull
two and a half times my body weight
and i'm the best deadlifter in the world
come on buddy go to that place come on
buddy come on
oh
i'm actually disappointed because i
always say unless you pass out or
yourself you're not trying hard enough
i know what more you want me to do
you did the before picture yeah this is
what you look like six weeks ago
yeah so let's do an after picture and
then we'll put them side by side and i
think you'll see a difference
[Music]
you can see where the two and a half
kilos go knowing i've just pulled that
figure
and that my strength has just been
proportionately to almost an elite level
achieved something that you know and
there's a feat of strength that i didn't
think i had in me
you've been beasted you put two and a
half kilos of lean mass on let's get it
yeah cheers eddie
calling rich just about ready
you